là selon kiev qui a réagi à d'ailleurs
ce matin l'ukraine et les occidentaux
ont empêché une escalade russe le
chancelier allemand qui va poursuivre ce
matin rencontrant aux alentours de 11
heures heure française le président
russe au kremlin avant même entrevue on
a appris tout à l'heure que les forces
russes déployées à la frontière était
retournée dans leurs garnisons l'un des
signes d'apaisement constatez vous allez
le voir que ces dernières heures comme
l'expliquent depuis moscou elena ball
chine
je rappelle que la russie dément
fermement toute velléité d'invasion de
l'ukraine d'autant plus cette semaine la
russie a déjà qualifié ces allégations
d'hystérie un jeu site de la part
américaine effectivement pour ce qui est
des signaux d'apaisement il hier
vladimir poutine a de mieux réunion
d'une très longue table comme l'ont noté
nombre de nombreux médias les réseaux
sociaux autour d'une très longue table
donc avec le ministre des affaires russe
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères pardon sergueï lavrov et le
ministre de la défense sergueï choïgou
et sergueï lavrov a effectivement
affirmé à vladmir poutine que les
pourparlers ne pouvait pas durer
indéfiniment mais que de son point de
vue du point de vue de la diplomatie il
y avait des chances ceci a été
interprétée évidemment par les analystes
en russie comme un signal très fort
d'apaisement sergueï lavrov a dit que
les pourparlers allaient se poursuivre
de son côté le ministre de la défense
lui a annoncé la fin progressive ou de
certaines manoeuvres militaires il a dit
que certaines étaient en phase d'être
achevée et d'autres allaient être
achevée très prochainement il s'agit là
les exercices très très très très très
conséquents à très grande échelle a
lancé depuis un mois un peu moins d'un
mois par la russie tous azimuts sur tous
les fronts dans toutes les mers avec
toutes les flottes engagé et des
exercices qui ont été évidemment
interprété ou delà même de la présence
militaire russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine comme une tentative
d'intimidation et
et le fait de montrer les muscles à
d'ailleurs le président français manuel
maintenant qui était en visite à moscou
il ya une semaine très exactement parmi
ces exigences hormis celles formelle de
ne pas envahir l'ukraine mais celle
concrètes et dès que vladimir poutine
envoie des signaux de désescalade en
tempérant tous ces exercices militaires
ce à quoi selon la france pas confirmée
par un autre se serait engagé le
président russe et donc on le voit hier
avec cette annonce que effectivement
c'est très probablement un signal envoyé
par la russie le fait que ces exercices
allait progressivement se terminer on